all right hi everybody thank you for
joining us today for a panel we're
calling the reality of virtual reality
we like the title it sounds dramatic my
name is dan Atkins I'm a publishing
producer here at Google focused on
daydream which for us is a combination
of both our AR and VR efforts but today
we're gonna be talking about VR and VR
as you guys know it's still very much an
emergent medium right it's one where
we're continuing to learn from every
product that comes out and more
importantly we're still in this phase
where app developers can still learn a
tremendous amount from game developers
and vice versa all right so we're lucky
enough today to be joined by two people
who really kind of run the spectrum of a
VR entertainment in the industry right
now and have been pretty prolific in
doing so both having shipped multiple
titles across multiple platforms so Nick
Jonathan thank you guys so much for
being with us yeah absolutely
I'm I'm hoping that we can start just by
hearing a little bit about who you guys
are and what brought you to VR and a
little bit about the products you've
been working on some think maybe we can
start with you sure my name is Nick
vasconcelos I am one of the founders of
turbo button we are a small indie studio
in LA we are three people strong and
just recently released this game along
together on Google daydream and the game
is you play as a kid's imaginary friend
kind of going on these adventures and
you have the power to like move things
in the environment and help this kid
find their lost dog so we've been going
for a couple years now we started
beginning of like 2015 started by doing
a couple of gear VR games and and then
this is our latest great I'm Jonathon
pleasure I work at a company and baobab
studios it was founded by Maureen fan
who used to run the farmville at
farmville franchises that Zynga and Erik
Darnell who was the writer director of
the meta gas
our films when he was at DreamWorks and
Larry Cutler who is our CTO who was the
head of global character animation
technology at DreamWorks and so we've
really come together as bringing kind of
traditional cinematic animation and
video game kind of talent to create
something new for a virtual reality and
you'll see on the screen we have three
pieces to date the first one invasion
most recently won an Emmy Award we're
very flattered to have that happen and
it's been a top performing app across
all the platforms asteroids will be
released this holiday season on daydream
and Rainbow crow will be coming out
sometime next year awesome and I think
we have a clip we'll watch on that one
on our on asteroids
[Music]
cool I love that clip very cool so I'm
wondering if we can start a little bit I
kind of want to take us through the
lifecycle of a product here and so I was
wondering if we can start with is a
little bit about the concept phase for
you guys and particularly ideation how
do you define a razor of what makes a
good idea for VR versus a bad idea
sure for us so turbo button we like only
do VR games like that is our focus is
the gaming side so a lot of times
there's kind of like two ways that will
start ideas one is with interaction is
which is probably like the biggest way
that we start things it's like does this
thing just feel good in VR
you know very often mechanics driven and
it doesn't even I think because like
everything is so early on like you were
saying it's like it it might not be the
most like mind blowing thing but even
just that the smallest interaction
design that can just feel really good
feels like 10 times better because it's
in VR right and like so it's just really
finding those core little moments that
feel really nice and then building
around those and then kind of like
sometimes we also come from the other
direction I'd be curious to know how you
guys think about it because it's like
it's just the Matic you know it's like
oh I want to be in this world or our
just a little moment of whether it's
like a character looking at you or
something like that is just it can that
can be the the hook the hook moment that
you build everything else around so I
don't yeah we come out of very much from
a narrative storytelling perspective
that's that's kind of the benefit of
having a guy like Erik Darnell is he's
very prolific in terms of his ideas and
has written a number of scripts that we
then start with these are the story
lines and he actually will pitch him to
the audience to the office as a whole so
we have these kind of brainstorming
sessions and then he runs through the
story and then we get feedback on the
story and kind of he takes that and
adjusts it and then we go into kind of
interactive sessions as kind of thinking
about wouldn't it be cool if we could do
this and so there's already starting to
be this emerging body of things that
happen in VR that people have attached
names to like the dollhouse effect do I
lean in and see little people and can
here into their houses - you know I'm in
water I put my head above water I put it
below I see under the water you know all
those types of things are super cool to
be watching created in this new medium
because it's just like you know when
smartphones came out and Angry Birds did
you know kind of the eye can actually
get the feel of like a slingshot out of
a piece of glass so this is that new
thing here and that's kind of how we go
through that process yeah and I think
like our razor for like what works or
doesn't work often comes down to like
comfort very often comfort Elise is like
that any little thing that can feel
weird can make you feel ill or dizzy or
something in VR it's like very easy to
do and I think we especially in our
earlier days of our company like we
would do a lot of experimentation around
like camera motion like a couple of our
games are like these third-person
experiences like along together where
cameras moving through the environment
and I can very easily make people feel
uncomfortable what we've like to develop
those systems to make them comfortable
we've like literally will be just like
laying on a sofa for about an hour
because we tried something that's like
oh god need the guys without the depth
perception at the office exactly exactly
we're not those guys and I'd say to
follow up on that in addition to the
kind of comfort level the things that
we're really focused on is that
interactivity that you're layering in
doesn't really detract from a narrative
that's of critical importance to us as
storytellers is that the interactivity
enhances the story as opposed to becomes
the focus of kind of the experience so I
mentioned like prototyping plays a
significant role in this as well right
you guys are trying to put things in
software as you're going and sort of
figuring out what makes what makes sense
what's the what's the razor for you guys
between sort of talking and I about an
idea and being convinced that it's worth
building that's a really tough question
because right now VR is a brand new
media if you come from kind of the film
television perspective that's a very
very well known vocabulary so if you go
to film school anywhere in the world
they're gonna talk about hard cuts off
cuts you know pan
zooms all these types of things that is
the language of storytelling in film and
television and once you get to VR it's
all thrown out the window you're no
longer on a set you know how longer have
this window that you're looking through
you are now in the experience and
there's stuff that can happen all around
so a lot of that stuff is all new so I
don't it it's really hard to say there's
a well-defined process for right
determining whether it works or it
doesn't because it's all brand new and
so that's part of the excitement but
also the challenge of working in this
medium totally getting getting it in
people's hands like as quickly as
possible has really been our our biggest
thing and it's hard I mean like you are
dealing with so many different problems
and things you're trying to overcome
during development and you don't often
have time to throw it at people but like
the sooner you can get in some of these
hands and like really find out what's
working and what's not like you know
there there are like I mean everybody
always wants to develop their best
practices for everything but I think
like we're not quite there yet for VR
they're like there are certain things
here and there that we like have learned
ourselves or heard from other developers
or whatever that we can try to avoid or
or specifically do because it makes
things better but like I think like
those rules are not hard and fast they
don't work in every situation something
that actually feels good in one
situation might feel terrible in another
and so like it's it's really just about
how other people react and and you know
it's the same I mean like no matter what
you're developing whether it's VR or not
like you are looking at this thing that
you're creating for so many hours that
it's hard to have any kind of
perspective on it until you see somebody
else react to it and I would say there's
a lot of stuff that when you come out of
the film and television or the video
game industry that actually is
applicable so we actually do do
storyboards even though those are
obviously 2d versus not an immersive
environment there is kind of a pacing in
a way to direct the scene even though
it's immersive and I'd say the the
beauty of what game engines like unity
are doing right now they call it the
real-time rebel
is the traditional animation process was
animating in Maya and then going into
render man and you'd have to wait
forever for this stuff to be rendered
out and then you'd look at it and go wow
that's not right and then you go back
and you have to redo it where is our
developers can sit just like is normal
in the video game business where you'd
be like why it's not normal they put on
their headset and they do their oh I
need to put a cup on the table oh I
should have this character come in from
here and they can go and make those
changes in real time and see it right
away and so that rapid prototyping is is
new for the animation industry but I
think very comfortable for the video
game industry yeah I think like we spent
a lot of time doing a lot of rapid
prototyping like game jams and like all
that kind of stuff just to like try
ideas out really quickly and kind of
throw them out and actually like
storyboarding is kind of like one of the
things that we had a hard time with it
first two is like just figuring out how
to like layout the space I remember our
artists like I was like hey we need like
a storyboard for this moment here kind
of the beats like you know figure out
what you want this look like and he's
drawing everything and he's like tiny
squares and shots and camera angles I'm
like no like hey I basically had to go
back in and like redraw the frames for
him but like very lightly and I was like
you know what feel free to draw outside
this you know think about how this whole
space feels and that really helped at
the time but now actually like seeing
things like Google blocks and like you
know unity is starting to do some of
their real-time VR editing tools and
stuff like that do you guys use that for
like laying stuff out we've used both
unreal and unity and we're currently
building our our current two pieces on
unity and so we use their Timeline
feature heavily yeah I bet and there's a
lot of really interesting things that
they're disrupting again in the
traditional animation industry but it's
quite comfortable for games it's it's
crazy I really wanted my hands more on
like actually editing scenes in VR cuz
actually like one of the hardest things
that I've I is like starting a new level
and really understanding what the scale
of that place feels like compared to
yourself we do a lot of like scaling up
and down of the character to like do the
toy box effect like you're talking about
so like we don't always it
hard to like imagine until you're
actually in it like what the scale of
that thing will be or boarding you know
there are companies out there developing
tools and people have tools internally
to do storyboarding and VR and that's
that's kind of some of the rapid
prototyping tools that are being
developed and used to out there right
now yeah
really helps so we have these these
rapid prototyping tools that allow us to
visualize things far more quickly an
experiment far more quickly which is
clearly a benefit to animation and games
as you guys have been going through this
rapid prototyping phase and you're
actually kind of moving from that
prototyping phase into building your
products what are what are some of the
biggest mistakes you've made trying to
author content in this new medium right
obviously there's the setting people
have a couch to be sick for a while when
things don't go super well what are some
others I'd say for us it's it's being
heavy-handed with the the users it's
pretty interesting because you have to
kind of prepare for everything from an
experienced VR user which there are
shockingly few out there right now just
given the penetration of the platforms
to complete newbies and so you'll find
people who will just jump in the
experience and though this start staring
off into the distance or they won't even
move their head and you have to kind of
plan for all those but I think a core
learning is that people just like in
every other media media they don't
really like to be forced what to do so
you have to kind of entice them to do
the things that you want so that they
can experience the story as it was meant
to be just told in our case so
heavy-handed things of like forcing them
into a position or doing something or
not allowing them to interact with
something has been less well-received
versus others audio is like a huge thing
for that right yes audio characters you
know we often say one of the things you
can do in VR is think like a magician if
you want the audience to look at you you
look at the audience if you want them to
look at something else you look at that
that happens in if you a big expressive
characters that's fairly easy to achieve
and then obviously audio cues it's a
little challenging with the audio
because not everything works that well
and spatialized audio not everybody has
you know right high tech headsets
you know actually mobile or something so
you've got to be able to kind of span
that gap and I think just like in games
you you know it often helps to kind of
think of the lowest common denominator
and build up from there yeah I think
like in actually maybe I you would
probably hate me for this but it's like
one of one of the things that we have
like have traditionally had problems
with in the past is actually like our
character interaction moments we've
definitely like we spent a lot a lot of
time prototyping like interactions and
gameplay mechanics and we still very
much value characters and narrative and
all that kind of stuff but like we do
come from a gaming background and like
and so we definitely have had times in
some of our products where like you know
we don't prototype our character
interactions early enough yeah and some
of them end up working and it's great
and yeah but like we've we've definitely
had moments where we build it out this
whole character interaction I'm like in
my head I'm like this is gonna be great
it's gonna be awesome and then like it
totally flops you know and now now
you're like dang I have to restructure
my whole like story a little moment so
we're just releasing this holiday as you
actually follow the two aliens where
we're in the first piece invasion who
came down invaded earth and we're
repelled by a cute little bunny Chloe
you follow them to their ship in outer
space and we found like when we first
put people out there you play actually a
helper robot on the ship and we gave you
like robotic hands and people just start
running around the ship jamming their
hands into various places thinking there
were r2d2 and they were gonna take over
control this year there's gonna be some
Easter eggs somewhere yeah and
completely missing the the narrative
yeah taking you know kind of the ball
that you could play fetch with a dog and
like hitting things trying to beat the
characters you know it's right it's a
very very interesting thing to run
through yeah you give somebody a ball to
play fetch with a dog and then they go
try to murder ever
thing with one of the things that
strikes me as you guys are talking about
this is is how some of the most profound
moments in your products at least for me
have been some of the most simple in
some ways right like envision is always
one of the first VR experiences I show
somebody and it's it's largely because
you have that moment where Chloe
I guess the buddy it just comes like
running right up to you and slides right
into your body and you really have this
moment of eye contact which is
incredibly powerful and it's like the
first medium I can think of where you
have eye contact and then similarly with
with along together the first really
interaction you have in the game is just
waving to another character and how
enduring that is and how much it
connects you to those characters have
you guys noticed a theme of simplicity
and these interactions that feels
important are you noticing that users
are growing into more complex
interactions as they continue to
progress through more VR content I think
like there's something about like simple
interaction so that like immediately
connect with people you know it doesn't
matter I like I don't think anybody's
sitting there going like oh man I'm like
bored of wait actually it might it might
get to that point now that I think about
it like if we have too many moments of
like you wave to this character it's
like okay like yeah I've done this in
the AR before like that's fine you know
no but I think so far it's been not so
much about like just like trying to be
like oh this is like a simple
interaction that'll be cool it's just
like what sells that moment and we're
not really necessarily worrying about
like how complex it should be I mean
especially for the very beginning of
sequence right like character looks at
you you wave at them like really like
pulling somebody into that experience
like you have to do something that is
like minimally or it's easy understand
and like as impactful as possible I feel
like I'm talking in circles a little bit
but I think like that is like that is
really key to especially as we are
getting mostly new users into VR like we
don't really make games assuming that
people have played VR before like we are
talking we're you know we're still
assuming like that this might be the
first time somebody is ever picking this
up so how do we make it as easy to get
into as
I don't think it's necessarily a
simplistic thing it's I mean the the
kind of magic of Chloe coming up to you
and bouncing around it's amazing to
watch people like you'll see people like
start hopping around on the floor trying
to jump back and forth and they're like
oh my god the AI behind that she's like
reacting to me and playing way like no
that's actually just a simple hop back
and forth there was eye tracking in
there which helped a lot but the key
piece being that it's more that it feels
like real life and to dig deeper on that
it is not that it's necessarily
photorealistic because you are actually
a bunny and that's a bunny and it's
clearly not real life but it's that it
feels natural in terms of the way that
you actually interact in your day-to-day
life and that's what you're striving for
and that could be a simplistic
interaction it could be complex
obviously we're gonna probably stumble
across the more simplistic ones because
they're gonna be easier for us to figure
out right now but as the medium grows
and gets better over time those will
obviously become more complex but it's
that key of replicating the fuel of
light yeah and I think actually like
thinking about the interactions by
themselves like they might be very
simple but I think like they can be
emotionally complex yeah it's a great
point
yeah and that's those are that that's
what really feels good yeah that makes
total sense it's funny muchnick's I
think the the reaction I see from a lot
of people you can always tell when the
bunny is about to hit actually that's
kind of fun too is like intentionally
doing things that are like slightly
uncomfortable yeah like not in a
physical way but it's in a way that
maybe oh oh
like it really kind of wakes you up and
like it's you going like it's really fun
to play with very cool so you both have
at this point you know ship multiple
products on on daydream on rift on all
sorts of platforms what have you learned
from those releases that you think
you'll apply to your next products like
what are the biggest takeaways you've
gotten from these experiences I'd say I
don't know if I have takeaways of the
like right now it's it's it's a very
challenging time as a developer because
if I'm to say you know in the West
forget China right now but in the West
there's arguably six platform
to port two and you know if you're
talking about like a video game company
that's on consoles or mobile devices
I mean it's Sony a Microsoft or Apple
and Google you know it's it's a much
more limited universe and so that's
challenging I hope that goes away and
narrows down something but the thing
that we're super excited about is
actually taking the best of day dream
which is kind of the portability
anywhere and kind of expanding that
power into these standalone headsets you
guys are launching one shortly um and
being able to bring more and more
rendering power into those standalone
headsets inside out tracking with tango
that solves a whole host of consumer
adoption problems like it's a pain in
the butt to put like boxes up there and
yeah run through that stuff so you guys
are really pushing into the area that we
want to go which is we think it's mobile
we think it's you know has inside out
tracking as a are pieces to be layered
into it and that's the stuff that were
or waiting for and excited about awesome
I think like for us the biggest thing
that we want to continue doing is like
character interaction which I'm you guys
love to you right it's it's it's fun
like it has a lot of you automatically
get a lot of personality out of it you
get a more connected feeling with that
world that you're in and we've done that
in like every one of our games so far
has been character driven and it's and
it's hard to do I mean in terms of costs
and stuff like that I think a lot of a
lot of things or a lot of people might
shy away from some of that sometimes or
or just I don't know I mean ever
obviously there are million different
types of games and everybody should play
all those different kinds but we like to
focus on those character moments and
stuff and like we're only three people
you know but our first like it's me and
my business partner and our first and
only hire so far has been a full time
animator totally which I think a lot of
people are like why you know oh but you
know that's really tell you
characters are core to what we do as
storytellers and yeah the simple idea is
that if you don't care about the
characters
you don't really care about the story
right and if you're dry developing story
driven games you know I think you
fundamentally have to start in that same
place is that the characters are
critical to that development of that
story I think I found too or at least
this is the feeling that I get when I
play that character driven stuff is that
having other characters around like very
quickly helps ground me in that world
and make me feel like I'm a part of that
story as well and again you don't have
to be human you don't have to be doesn't
have to be photorealistic right not at
all
and I think for us the way we like to
describe that that framework because
when I was in video games I used to say
video games were just interactive
animation and animation was just a non
interactive video game and I've since
learned that not that smart more complex
than that the way we we talk about it a
bail Bob is we want kind of the empathy
of film the agency of video games
because you know you have that
interactive medium and the motivations
of real life and that kind of comes
together when you get it right in a
magical way yeah that's that's kind of
our goal of our company so we're a
little low on time any advice about how
any advice you have for folks who are
thinking about starting up on daydream
ways to get started things good good
tools of the trade good tricks I think
from like the design side of it at least
like we had just like understanding the
capabilities of the controller is super
important I think early on and
development of long together we were
trying to do a lot of stuff with the
gyroscopes and the accelerometer and had
just all these features that were trying
to do a bunch of stuff with and I'm not
saying this is always the case but for
us like really scaling back and saying
okay like what is the simplest way for
people to interact with this controller
and interact with the world kind of like
you were saying like earlier really
figuring out the simple interactions
that have a big impact and that we felt
like doing too much with the controller
in general even though there are all
these things you can do with it really
increased like the the learning curve
quite a lot so I think really
getting your controls like streamlined
if you're doing a game or even just
anything with interaction I think that's
like a big place to start for daydream
awesome I'd say I mean obviously unity
makes it a much easier prospect to get
into mobile devices obviously should be
working in a game engine I do think that
your point around controllers is really
well said there was an interesting stat
that that oculus released last last week
about oculus can at oculus connect
around the in the pieces that had
effective use of the controller which
there's as a three-dollar Oller as well
dramatically increased engagement in
length of viewer time so I'd say
definitely wrap in in a controller
scream and and I'd say finally don't try
to do too much too fast you know
bite-sized experiments see how it goes
to learn you know that's probably the
fastest way to get something good out
there
awesome well I want to thank you both
for for being here today really looking
forward to seeing what you guys do next
in terms of your next products and and
thank you for giving us like a quick
education on on VR and VR storytelling
you